- [Voiceover] "Ksenia
wants to chop broccoli
"and carrots for a competition.
"It takes her the same number of seconds
"to chop each carrot, and
it takes her the same number
"of seconds to chop each broccoli head.
"Her goal is to chop
at least 20 vegetables
"with a time limit of
540 seconds," all right.
"The graph below represents the set
"of all combinations of
carrots and broccoli.
"Inequality A," let's see,
"Inequality A represents
"the range of all combinations
Ksenia wants to chop."
Because she wants to chop
at least 20 vegetables.
So, that's what Inequality
A is representing,
that she wants to chop
at least 20 vegetables.
So, all this blue shaded
area and even the line,
is a solid line so it
includes point on the line.
These are all of the scenarios
where she's chopping
at least 20 vegetables,
all this blue area
including the blue line.
And it says, "Inequality
B represents the range
of all combinations she can
chop with her time limit."
So, Inequality B, this is
all of the combinations
where she is within her time limit,
where she is not spending
any more than 540 seconds.
"What is the least number of carrots
Ksenia can chop while achieving her goal?"
Well, her goal, remember she wants to chop
at least 20 vegetables.
So, you want to be in the blue area.
You want to be in the solution set
for Inequality A, which
would be the blue area
or on the blue line.
And she wants to achieve her goal
of meeting the time limit.
So, she needs to also
be in the solution set
for Inequality B so she also has to be in
the green area or on the green line.
And so the overlap of the two,
if she's meeting both constraints,
it's going to be all of this area.
This is the overlap
of the two solution sets.
So, in this overlap where is
the least number of carrots.
"What is the least
number of carrots Ksenia
can chop while achieving her goal."
So, if we see here, the
least number of carrots,
you might tempted to
say, "Okay, 20 carrots,
that is in the solution set."
That would be 20 carrots
and zero broccoli heads
but you can actually find a combination
that has even fewer carrots.
You can go all the way to this point
because remember the points on the lines
are also included in the solution sets,
because they are solid
lines not dash lines.
So, this point right over here,
10 carrots and 10 broccoli heads
actually meets her goal.
So, let me write that down.
10 carrots and
10 broccoli, 10 broccoli heads.
Let me just write that, 10 broccoli heads.
So, that's the least amount.
If you wanted to somehow figure out
less than 10 carrots, in
any of those scenarios
there's no overlap.
You know, if you say,
"Oh, is there any way
"to do nine carrots?"
If you look over here there's no overlap
at c equals nine between
the two solution sets.
So, the minimum right over here
is actually the point of intersection
of these two lines.
10 carrots, 10 broccoli heads
that's the combination
that has her chopping
the minimum number of carrots
while achieving, frankly, her goals,
both of her goals.
Being under time and chopping
at least 20 vegetables.